13 years after a valley teenager was
robbed and killed his mother says today
justice was finally served devon
phillips was the last of four men
involved in the death of eric braille to
be sentenced and now brill's mother is
not holding back
a really disgusting process to me a
13-year fight karen brill says is
finally over devon phillips sentenced to
nine years in prison for the death of
eric brill in 2009 they stole my life
from me they stole everybody
killed him
phillips along with nadine hicko devonte
wash and arthur moore are now all behind
bars for robbery and murder the four men
robbed and opened fire at brill and his
friends outside a house party in 2009
near sloan lane and charleston as they
all ran away brill was shot in the head
while another victim was shot four times
but survived before the sentence
phillips offered these words i know that
sorry will never be enough to bring back
the child's loss i would never be able
to estimate the pain you have to live
with as a mother after the incident
police hit a wall in the investigation
for seven years but eventually found
phillips was sentenced to nine years for
voluntary manslaughter with a deadly
weapon and has two prior convictions for
robbery today with all four men finally
in jail brill's mother says there is
finally some closure i consider myself
fortunate to have had somebody
held accountable even though i'm not
happy with the sentences
that they've received
eric i guess you know he got justice
brill's mother also tells us she will
continue to fight and push to keep these
four men behind bars she says she will
push for stiffer laws and lobby on her
son's behalf